[Music]
big shout out to hellofresh with
hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
so go to hellofresh.com fury 16 and use
code fury16 for up to 16 free meals and
three free gifts that's hellofresh.com
fury16 for up to 16 free meals and three
free gifts hellofresh america's number
one meal kit hey everybody welcome back
to wrists of fury we're here at the
zodiac studios as part of the moon tower
comedy festival in austin i'm kelsey
cook i'm so excited to be shooting new
episodes again and i got two amazing
guests so please give it up for josh
adam myers and jessica kirsten yay
we just came from the yeshiva academy
here in texas just a very very polite
energy that i feel like is about to get
out of control really quickly like you
two we were saying before are some of
the loudest comics
yeah right on stage but offstage i'm
very down and depressed and
um i cry a lot
oh good yeah but i'll give this my all
you know i'm just gonna i'm gonna have
to stretch before we start just so that
you can give me some time to just do you
want to warm up right now i'm sure you
could yeah
wow this is
okay
get the nipple tweaks
yeah
thank you
really get focused
are things feeling warmer
yeah i'm ready i'm ready
what is this against um softball
we're playing a little round of softball
okay good because i'm a dyke
you feel at home
yeah good yeah yeah
uh what is your guys's foosball
experience coming into this
you wanna go first yeah i played a lot
uh we had one in our temple um really
yeah okay i went to temple i used to
play so um
and i would win sometimes because i was
very angry as a kid so i'd play the
jewish you know the other kids the nerds
and i would whip their ass but i have a
feeling that i'm not gonna do very well
against you
which is fine i'm okay with that i think
josh might i think you might be good at
this no uh i do play a lot of sports but
this is just a game can i be honest i
always thought this was kind of like
lame because there's like it just was
something that you know it was like they
didn't really have it at the bars you'd
see it and you know it's it's just
like i always played against like when i
really started playing it against my
like nieces and nephews and and you know
you just kind of like moved the table to
get it to score so that's right that's
how i played very very like
unprofessional in this game okay and is
there a strategy for why you're playing
forward and you're playing defense oh i
didn't even know what i was playing but
um
i just i'm going to see how he does with
the scoring and if he sucks then i'll
put him back into the perfect this is
the defense yeah i'll put him back to
the defense and then i'll do the
scorings if he doesn't do well we
figured we figured if yeah we'd
eventually switch because we'd be when
we start losing i'd i'd be like let me
see how i could do defending your risk
of fury i feel like he may have to go do
the back end because that's what he
likes is the back end right back
all back from the back baby yeah our
comment section is gonna [ __ ] love it
yeah
so many puns okay so we're gonna play
one game to five just to start
have a little light banter just get
warmed up
okay
sound good i hope we win
what do we get if we score one goal
i mean we didn't think of
rewards for one goal because that's such
a sad can we get a bagel
with locks yeah with cream cheese and
some onion and tomatoes
[Music]
are you guys ready yeah okay okay
let's give this a go
oh jesus
she's coming for you dude
dude get the guy in front of me i can't
don't yell at me
come on man dad
all right screen we got a screamer do
you have to do it that hard yeah
i know no other way
so now we start if we start okay you're
the yellow
okay now i have to tell you so there's
technically no spinning allowed
oh come on man i can't believe it listen
don't
[Laughter]
what is that passing thing
it's her like you know what you're just
like you're just resetting the ball no
no no that's a lot the sp you got it you
got it come on oh no you were [ __ ]
you might as well just move the thing
over now
god you just gave it right are you you
better stop judging me i don't like the
passing
i don't want to be passing i don't like
that you're pissed
oh
you know what
i'm going to start cutting
you want a drink
after playing this game i'm sober i was
i can't believe i just scored on myself
i know that was that was a good i just
did my own goal to myself
you got this
you're getting too close
oh yeah i get them wait no can you wait
yeah
i got you i'm gonna give it back all
right go for it this is very upsetting
oh the fake [ __ ] with the jar
do you see what you're doing i thought i
thought i was gonna fake her out
it's like the cat i know i know
oh i'm pretty good at this
how quickly people feel good right
before i make them feel like [ __ ]
never speaking
i have to say i have saved a couple
it's not bad right
now what do i do now you got to do what
she just did like tap it and slap it
the old tablet the song by r
oh my god i can't
focus
[ __ ]
next time will you do it harder so that
all my childhood traumas come up at one
time
shall we move these
if you score we're winning
you can't take all [ __ ] five points
oh no oh no
can you oh you got it you got it you got
it right yeah there it is i just set
nope
don't do it don't do it we're friends
don't you oh goody
am i allowed to lean over
[ __ ]
you know i felt better about myself
today because i did like meditations
and then
i risked her
did we lose already no i just was taking
back the cheating points but jessica
it's four to zero great
josh
she just oh [ __ ] you sorry just
impressively there aren't you
god
i love that the crew is laughing because
they've watched you do this over and
over again
it's so smooth
i have never felt like less of a man
this is the most like it's funny to see
her actually do it in person
it's it's really cool it's like you're
watching jordan in his prime oh my god
you know what i mean you're going to
ruin my life you say things like that
i'm very impressed with the passing the
tapping the thank you it is it's um
it's a lot thanks guys we feel so good
you did lose 5-0
that was uh that was we're going to get
one shot on the shoulder
do you think that was round one but
we're gonna do round two and it's gonna
be easier for you guys to beat me so
come over come over here we're gonna
pick some handicaps
and try to spice it up a little bit
okay so i'm gonna pick a ball
and then you guys pick a ball
thank you we each pick one no just as a
team all right what did you get one one
one okay so you guys get to start with
two points
that gasp i know i'm excited um i got
four so
i have to
stand on one leg
i can only score from the back
and you guys are gonna do a spelling bee
with me so i have to try and spell
difficult words as i play so i have
three handicaps basically and you guys
start with two points so we'll see if
that helps okay
she's still gonna win
all right so do i move two of these over
yeah we're up by we're up two nothing to
love as they say two lives
do you guys want to stay where you are
did you like that do you want to mix it
up what do you think
i don't know what do you think
i'll try okay i'm not very i wasn't very
good at that part so maybe all right
i'm pretty good at scoring is there like
wait before we go any further are there
any like tips that you can give us to at
least
seem somewhat competitive
sure so
um
you always want to be i mean it sounds
basic but be mindful of where you are
putting your defenders some people will
do this and then you're obviously
leaving so much more so you want to try
and take away as much of the goal as
possible obviously um
i mean there's so many things i could
teach you is there something specific
you want help on how to stop you
like that
but also you're trusting that i'm
telling you the truth right now i might
have just [ __ ] you but
if i take my shirt off would that
distract you
my breasts are very uneven
and my bra looks like a dog toy
oh my god a dog toy yeah it's really in
bad shape it's just
not on yeah it's bad it's so wet right
now um okay
should we do this yeah let's do it okay
i'm gonna let you start with the ball
okay wait i'm on one leg and i can only
score from back here okay
go for it can you move your guys over a
little bit so you're not blocking mine
that would not
that would not help me
oh
okay i can't spin like that okay and so
you guys have to also give me some
spelling words apparently
say it
lagoria
what orlaria
what
i think it's gonorrhea but can we just
say gonorrhea because that that's
actually a word that i i don't know what
the [ __ ] a logarithmic yeah josh's
crotch right yeah logaria spell that
um
does that count if i got it like caught
like that that's going to be like
let's take a hacky section yeah that was
the best
did i already [ __ ] it up yep
[ __ ]
okay if i [ __ ] it up
[Laughter]
okay you guys can take a point because i
[ __ ] up the word
i just did that thing again
[Music]
she just passed it back because i can
only score from back here oh [ __ ] oh
sweet oh oh did you [ __ ] oh
um
what is that word by the way
we have an examination yeah can we have
a definition
oh my leg is cramping
are you kidding me okay
you have to now not stand on both legs
can you float score
you have to score from that yoda can you
yoda fight me you have to
be
off both legs score from over there and
we get another point you should get you
should get the the production manager
you have to tell him how to move his
wrist and like in a headset that he's
wearing because this is unfair and then
you have to spell
and this is why we checked mic levels
before we started because we knew
there would be some amount of animal
sounds get off both legs and spell
okay
oh my god okay um what is the next word
hold on we don't start playing yet
because i this you know these are not
easy words
i'm the one phillip
slippitus
is making me look
really in bad shape no wait yeah you
can't score oh my god
okay what is the word
silly
syllabus
celephasis
silicilla peppas
which is a great picture silly texas
[ __ ] man if you want a great slice go to
silipeppus
philippe is on fourth straight and
second avenue i don't even know
silly
cis collapses
is
syllabus this not a real word is it this
is a real word syllabus
s
why wait should you be playing while
you're doing this oh no yeah or like
okay
s-y yeah
yes
[ __ ] dude here maybe i shouldn't go back
up front that's why dude i'm trying to
i'm trying to read [ __ ] celebs
oh
she's like i'm trying to i'm trying to
check her out
s y l l
e
sis
you know what did i just get it yes
oh
[ __ ] that was actually
yeah
thank you so much what does that word
mean no one knows i think they're just
making up things right now did you make
up that word it's amazing can i take a
point for that yes that was unbelievable
come on
what that was a hard word that's a
really crazy word
i should i should get a point for just
being able to figure out how to say it i
said it right 46 times you do not
sneeze oh this is this is one that all
jews have
what
eczema
is that it i'll say it right
and also we'll throw in rosacea too
okay eczema rotation okay
ec
there's a z in there and there's an s i
just don't know where [ __ ]
unbelievable well i just would but i
feel like i should still
e c x
take your time yeah spell it out
i've sounded out
and spell it out
i'm right so far with ec
so far
easy
z-e-m-a
did i get it
i hope you get fat
big shout out to hellofresh with
hellofresh you get farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
you can skip trips to the grocery store
and count on hellofresh to make cooking
at home easy fun and affordable that's
why it's america's number one meal kit
i've actually been using hello fresh for
years i'm obsessed with them the food is
amazing and being on the road so much i
love that the boxes just come right to
my door pre-portioned ingredients i have
to do so little to have seriously
amazing meals and since the holidays can
be so hectic hellofresh helps out a ton
they cut back on meal prep and obviously
going to the grocery store so you can
spend less time in the kitchen and more
time with your friends and family and if
you're going to entertain this holiday
season they've got you covered they've
got charcuterie boards holiday cheese
boards and skinny dip dark chocolate
peppermint almonds hella fresh offers 50
menu and market items to choose from
every week including vegetarian calorie
smart and gourmet options so there's
always a ton of variety the new year is
a great time to focus on what's
important to you whether it's saving
money by ordering less takeout learning
to cook or prioritizing your wellness
hellofresh is here to help with endless
options to make cooking at home simple
and enjoyable hellofresh cuts back on
time in the kitchen so you can spend it
on your other resolutions with meals
that are ready in around 30 minutes or
less plus with quick and easy meals
including 20 minute recipes and low prep
and easy clean up you can have an even
faster route to putting food on the
table hellofresh is 72 cheaper than a
restaurant meal of the same quality so
you can save on average over 65 dollars
per month when you order hellofresh
instead of grocery shopping that's more
money to put toward your other 2022
goals hellofresh also offers the
flexibility you need to easily customize
your order online or in your app i love
it because i can change my meals for
that week if i'm on the road i can skip
a week they make it so easy so go to
hellofresh.com
fury16 and use code fury 16 for up to 16
free meals and 3 free gifts that's
hellofresh.com fury16 for up to 16 free
meals and 3 free gifts hellofresh
america's number one meal kit
i shouldn't have been playing defense
man well nothing happened and i'm
reading the words because you're blind i
said phillip pistas and i said let's see
and i said
eczema my god
that was really fun you're perfect yeah
that was unbelievable that you scored
from the back with one leg up
and was spelling the words
thank you or and you scored like
like amazing right away
or we just suck no i mean we block some
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
this has been so fun so far i really
[ __ ] love doing this by the way i
just like
the vibe
in our teams i feel like i just look
like cotton candy yeah you guys are so
like oh yeah
[Laughter]
for my life
a lifetime of it um okay so for the
final round we are going to play a game
called two ball
so
we each start with a ball we say one two
three go in order to get a point you
have to score both balls if we each
score one it's a wash oh okay okay
here's the thing if you guys lose do you
want to play defense yeah
your punishment is that you each
have okay wow this is a
new portion of the show
and we lost all our sponsors it's great
okay
someone's gonna write flashlight there's
so many out there that you can use write
me a letter that i just assaulted him
and they feel triggered
i think probably earlier from the nipple
tweaking if there was a time it was i
don't have nipples so if you're
triggered
by that just know that my nipples fell
off she's all ariel soft rounds
all areola
and i'm not going to get into what
happened
oh these guys have smiley faces they do
just for the fans at home to know that
these guys are
all on uh
on wellbutrin
they're all in ecstasy
okay that's what we should that's what
we should have done that is what you
should have
you're
it's just the rhythm of the life
of the night
oh yeah
and all right so here's what you got to
do so i'll be playing backwards we're
all having a bad trip
the rules need to be like so obscure
like okay so i'll play backwards while i
stand on one leg and sing um
you guys are out of
your minds and i love it so much this is
the best i took two balls the two ball
you have to make you guys lose
[Laughter]
you have to get them both in
okay
for 30 seconds oh no
we love each other i hate roasting great
because we love each other i'm gonna do
a nice roast so i'm gonna do a nice
roast okay
yeah i can i'm not i can't be like a
nice deckle
yeah nice did you have decor i'm gonna
roast you as an old jewish woman
yeah okay
he's an old jewish woman what's with
that shirt you can't buy another one you
like freddie mercury
[Music]
and i started so we do one two three go
so are you ready for this
okay all right one i don't know what
time two two three go
oh good job
no and i just give it to her
no and now
okay no it's mine
it's fine oh hold on it's fine
it's a tight zoom
okay one two three go
in but that was amazing
come on dude this is it this is our shot
i scored a kelsey cook again
go go
that is your clip for instagram josh is
that you got it come on get it back i'm
feeling it i'm feeling good
go go go you [ __ ]
come
oh on on oh my god you gotta do it
oh my god
did i just peek i peeked
well oh my god come on oh my god you're
doing good come on
traumatized don't get it don't forget it
don't
worry no no no
okay don't you set up
don't you do it
oh goody
please no please
this is just suzy just slowly slowly
work it over this is the end
and then
my totally
so lift lift up on it
there you go oh [ __ ] you
come on
oh that's a wash because you guys are
the first one
hey it's a wash it's a wash
okay
one two three go
come on man
i
i'm proud of myself
no i'm not
that was a good that was a good block
though
you're doing great we we're doing great
yeah okay you brought one in i did
man one two three go
huh
[ __ ]
oh my god
i'm ready
ready yeah two three go
oh
come on
no see you can't hold the other ball
while you're scoring on the other one
they were both being held and do
something that's what she said
oh no
you got it you got it come on pass it up
to me i'm up here waiting no yeah there
you go that was smart
oh [ __ ] you oh no oh no no no just come
on
i have to go to the hospital
do we lose no no no no wait wait don't
we i've scored twice oh it's a washer
all right one two three go
oh josh i can't believe you scored twice
that's very good thank you very much
oh nice block
nope
oh my god
i'm just going to do that thing with you
passing it down to that dude oh you can
you how can you excuse me you have to do
that if it's a dead one
look at them losing their mouths
listen no
if there's a ball right here
that and you can't touch it you have to
move with your fingers
there's no this is a crock of
my neck is killing me
you guys are
this is the most jewish game in the
world because we just all right patch
the ball
hurry up i got a [ __ ]
no wait we weren't ready
i'm very happy that i scored it just
take this moment in you're good you're
doing so good i really am i just wanted
to score once you did it you feel alive
yeah
wash there's a wash
all right okay one two three go
[Music]
why don't you just grab it and throw it
in the goal
come on we can wash it out
oh no
oh
oh good
good get it get it get it
did i do that no i know i it's called a
stuff where you block it and it goes in
oh really
what's it called a stuff oh i thought of
steph i'm like who's steph
i stuck stuff yep very sexually
i know i'm gonna go back
[Laughter]
your face will look just like that
all right here we go
all right this is it you guys so four
zero are you breaking a sweat i am these
coins it's [ __ ] hot in here
all right okay ready one two three go
[ __ ] up and there yeah yep okay well
that was our time guys thanks so much
all right we're
at josh adameyers on all social media
joshadenmeiers.com
rosie o'donnell.com
okay so
let's put 30 seconds on the clock each
you guys have to do a little rest of
each other all right
i'm going to roast him as an old girl
i'm so not good at this i know don't
just i don't know why you're wearing
that shirt are you gay it says queen
you like it in your [ __ ]
your breath smells i don't know what
does it smell like guys
i had fish earlier this morning i don't
know if it was salmon or uh
or a goldfish
my grandson
left his goldfish out and i was starving
is that the germans
you guys love each other
[Music]
can we please can we just just shove
these balls in our ass can that be our
can that just be
yeah like i could shield one all the way
across the river
we did that in the camps
we did everything in the camps oh my god
you guys
you guys are the best josh i mean did
you technically just plug everything you
want to plug
yeah uh
again it's very sexual on the show at
josh adam myers also
finger joshadmires.com
jessica where can people see that
beautiful face of yours
um
uh i you can find me at
jessicacarson.com
at jessecarson on instagram
um and uh yeah and i'm on tick tock at
jessica kirsten you can check out all my
tick tock videos they're amazing
you're doing tic tacs totally
i got suspended because i said the word
threesome but you can see uh pictures of
14 year olds boobs and they don't get
suspended
that is all technically true
we'll go follow jessica everywhere
um you can follow me on instagram and
tick tock at kelsey cook comedy
oh [ __ ] tick tock and uh you can see
me on tour at kelseycook.com thank you
guys so much for doing this uh please
subscribe to all these comedy on youtube
to see more of the episodes go follow
josh and jessica they're amazing and uh
i love you both you're amazing
you're amazing thank you thank you we
scored yes you both scored twice
yep all right i scored once you scored
twice two or three times
twice twice amazing yeah three in the
team
yeah three as a team did you see how
fast she was like
twice
yeah thank you what's the most you made
like hustling at like a comedy club in
like portland i made 40 bucks the other
night
really yeah i just do like ten dollars a
game i'm not trying to ruin anybody's
financial future
and nobody's beat you
um there's been a couple guys who are
nationally ranked players that show up
and try to hustle me and then they they
can beat me eventually yeah
which is not a good feeling but they're
really good they're really on the show i
can't wait till there's that one comic
that [ __ ] just i don't think so there
won't be a comment there won't be a
comic nickname is good
bronger is good is he no idea no
i have no idea okay i just want to give
him a shout out really fun okay
all right we'll see you guys next time
[Music]
you